[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde la planète enflammée où sont
les responsabilités un été de chien sale
temps pour la planète des perturbations
climatiques extrêmes des sécheresses
maximales des inondations dévastatrices
canicules terrestre et maritime tempête
et ouragan biodiversité frappée mutilé
mort et blessé humain animaux aussi rien
ne nous fut épargné au cours de cette
période estivale 2022 et ce nuage
catastrophique fut quasiment
ubiquitaire en France avec des brasiers
d'une violence inouïe à l'ensemble du
bassin méditerranéen en Asie et en
Afrique au Moyen-Orient et autour des
contrées du Pacifique on a un criminel à
juste titre le réchauffement climatique
mais pas que du fait de la violence et
de l'accumulation de ces phénomènes
extrêmes de leur périodicité aussi
seulement deux à trois degrés Celsius de
plus ce qui constitue le baromètre météo
estivale quand la nature fait des ciels
et c'est la catastrophe assurée un
contrario l'absence d'élévation de la
température n'aurait pas été un barrage
aux intempéries climatiques mais on
aurait à coup sûr freiné le cours
catastrophique et les conséquences à la
fois naturelle et humaine quand le vert
est plein à ras bord la goutte
supplémentaire provoque le débordement
alors on a un criminé à juste titre la
responsabilité humaine moins pour en
criminaliser individuellement les
comportements en fait peu nombreux que
par des dégâts causés par la main de
l'homme au service d'une économie
consumériste imprévoyant des risques
gaspilleuse des ressources et une fine
et myope écologiquement les entreprises
les États les territoires les
organisations internationales ont aussi
leur part de responsabilité c'est ce que
nous allons discuter avec mes invités
Fabienne Keller vous êtes heureux député
ancien maire de Strasbourg Brice Lalonde
vous êtes ancien ministre de
l'Environnement et ancien ambassadeur
pour le climat Daniel salmon vous êtes
sénateurs d'îles et Vilaine pour le
parti Europe Écologie Les Verts
Abderrahmane mebtoum vous êtes
professeur des universités et experts
international Hervé Le truth que nous
avons en visio-conférence vous êtes
climatologue et vous êtes membre de
l'Académie des sciences
[Musique]
pas question de s'éterniser sur les
coupables mais plutôt à partir du
panorama que j'ai dressé d'établir le
niveau des responsabilités d'abord au
niveau des individus
9/10 des départs de feu sont d'origine
humaine très peu relèvent de
comportements criminels mais sont
provoqués par des conduites à risque
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire Fabienne
Keller alors ce constat est évidemment
très alarmant c'est
un sujet de mobilisation absolue d'où
les interdictions d'ailleurs de tout
barbecue de toute cigarette dans dans
l'espace public l'information à ce sujet
pour que chacun soit vigilant sur les
comportements puis après il y a les
comportements délictueux la personne qui
le fait volontairement pour après
regarder le feu malheureusement il y en
a qui parfois réplique d'ailleurs leur
comportement et là la justice doit faire
son oeuvre et condamner bien sûr
sévèrement ceux qui en fait démarre un
processus qui est d'autant plus grave
que les incendies en période de forte
chaleur
se répandent très facilement pour peu
qu'il y ait du vent et on n'arrive plus
trop à les maîtriser donc c'est une
action qui doit être
complétée sur les différents volets
rendre chacun attentif au fait qu'il
peut générer un feu moi-même j'étais
dans les Cévennes et j'étais très étonné
le train pouvait on a découvert que il
générait des intersals puis c'est un
vieux train et que on a dû l'arrêter au
motif qu'il pouvait mettre le feu à des
à débroussailles donc un regard qu'on
n'avait pas besoin d'avoir jusque là
parce que la situation n'était pas aussi
difficile mais aussi des mesures de
prévention de bon sens et puis des
condamnations pour ceux qui le font
volontairement alors Hervé letrott
est-ce que au niveau du GIEC on a pris
conscience de cet aspect individuel
c'est à dire ces risques qui sont pris à
la fois par les individus mais on verra
également par les entreprises et les
états oui oui je pense qu'il a prise de
conscience elle est forte elle est
importante moi ce que je trouve c'est
qu'on laisse assez peu de place au futur
que dans et le futur c'est un futur qui
va se décliner en fonction de ce qu'on a
vu déjà ces dernières années et de ce
qui va continuer dans les années qui
viennent moi j'ai toujours un petit peu
bien sûr qu'on a des situations qui sont
des situations alarmantes qui a des gens
qui se comportent mal il y a des choses
mais au-delà de ça il y a une évolution
qui est une évolution dont on sait
qu'elle va continuer il y a pratiquement
pas de possibilités pour empêcher en
fait cette cette situation là donc on
est dans un cadre qu'on a qu'on a besoin
de de regarder tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire quelque chose qui a
évolutif fortement évolutif qui va
continuer à être évolutif donc je pense
qu'il faut vraiment prendre cela de
manière
extrêmement sérieuse je trouve que
on parle souvent de ce qu'il y a parait
au jour
quelques fois comme il était comme des
éléments qui sont
qui sont qui sont vraiment des des
éléments qu'on en a pas su contraindre
on n'a pas su mais la planète ne nous
attend pas pour toutes ces choses-là on
est vraiment dans un domaine qui est
aujourd'hui un domaine très très
difficile à
saisir et qui est quelque chose qui va
aussi voilà qui qui va aussi nous nous
donner des éléments pour le seul futur
dont on voit qu'on va prendre en compte
parce que ils sont ils sont pas
difficiles ils sont pas faciles à
mettre en jeu il s'est des éléments qui
sont
qui seront difficiles à
manifester alors je suis dans une salle
là où il y a beaucoup de monde
je rappelle que vous êtes à Sciences Po
mais je vais poser la même question à
nos invités est-ce qu'il faut une
nouvelle culture écologique brise
Lalonde parce que c'est
il faut quand même on prend la prise de
conscience et là mais la prise de risque
est aussi là oui bien sûr il va falloir
porter notre regard de la nature c'est
quand même depuis 1988 qu'on sait tout
ça donc on a beaucoup tardé à agir moi
ce qui m'a frappé cet été c'est que
c'est au sud ouest que les incendies se
sont déchaînés alors que dans le sud-est
on est habitué au feu là il y a pas eu
d'incendie majeurs donc il y a la
culture du feu était beaucoup plus
présente donc maintenant c'est dans le
Sud-Ouest on sait que l'urbanisation a
joué un rôle très important bon on sait
maintenant que la forêt il ne faut pas
il ne faut pas trop l'habiter quoi voilà
il faut la garder à l'abri en quelque
sorte de l'urbanisation des transports
et même les lignes électriques mais vous
parlez de la forêt justement c'est une
question qui est intéressante 70% de la
surface forestière nationale et privée
et il y a soit 30% du territoire et il y
a plusieurs millions de propriétaires
forestiers à qui incombe l'entretien de
la forêt et je évidemment je fais
allusion au brasier de Landiras et de la
thèse de bûche ou plus des milliers
d'hectares de forêts sont partis en
fumée alors c'est qui le responsable
alors on sait très bien qu'il faut
défricher il ne faut pas qu'il y ait
d'éléments combustible au sol et c'est
ce qui se passe dans dans le sud-est
dans des friches on fait attention à
tout autour de la maison on défriche de
manière à ce que le fun puisse pas
s'approcher et de la même année on a des
pare-feux on a l'habitude et on a cette
extraordinaire système qui s'appelle
Prométhée où on a le gai on a des tours
on voit dès qu'il y a une fumée hop on
avertit les pompiers les canadairs etc
ça marche bien alors simplement ça va
être pire puisque comme le dit le
professeur le truc malheureusement ça ne
va pas s'arrêter et donc
vraisemblablement il va falloir changer
et les espèces peut-être forestières
elles-mêmes et peut-être que une des
questions les plus importantes
sous-jacentes c'est la question de l'eau
la question va parler de ça vous verrez
amplement alors Daniel Salman sur la
question de la forêt vous vous pensez
qui est responsable puisque les
propriétaires sont privés
premier responsable c'est le
réchauffement climatique c'est à dire
que tous les problèmes que vous venez de
citer à 25 degrés il était le sujet est
bien moindre aujourd'hui 40 degrés dans
10 ans peut-être 45 enfin je vais un
petit peu loin mais effectivement quand
on va atteindre les 45 degrés la forêt
va devenir extrêmement inflammable donc
le responsable premier c'est le
réchauffement climatique lié quand même
à l'homme bon mais une fois qu'on a dit
ça aujourd'hui effectivement ce que
disait monsieur le trotte c'est qu'on
est dans une une période où il y a des
choses les dés sont lancés on va dire et
il va falloir gérer au mieux et donc
effectivement il va falloir il y a des
obligations de débroussaillement
débroussaillage près des près des
maisons effectivement aujourd'hui les
pompiers des fois sont accaparés pour
sauver les biens les biens immobiliers
et ne vont pas n'ont pas le temps
d'aller lutter contre le feu en forêt
donc ça il va falloir avoir une vraie
culture là-dessus de préservation des
habitations mais qui va être là
peut-être individualisé pour que les
pompiers puissent se concentrer sur les
flammes et puis comme vous le disiez
tout de suite très certainement éviter
d'aller se promener en forêt sur
certaines journées qui sont vraiment
aujourd'hui très très dangereuses pour
la forêt puisque la moins d'étincelle
vous l'avez dit ça s'est passé dans le
Sud-Ouest cette année mais pourquoi
parce que c'est un ou deux faits qui ont
fait que ça c'est enflammé là mais ça
peut s'enflammer à tout moment partout
est-ce qu'il y a eu des incendies
majeurs et de la sécheresse et des
inondations en Algérie
l'été passé bon et qu'est-ce qu'il y a
une culture si vous voulez on parle pas
du climat pour le moment mais
concrètement est-ce que le peuple
algérien et qui est concentré sur cette
question là bon l'Algérie a connu une
véritable catastrophe l'année passée
notamment au Kabylie
bon cette année c'est surtout l'Est qui
a été
touché bon effectivement depuis surtout
l'année passée il y a une prise de
conscience dans la mesure où les dégâts
ont été très très importants il y a eu
effectivement des actions
de Crimée criminels effectivement ça
c'est il faut le reconnaître mais aussi
on a connu des 47 50 degrés c'est on n'a
jamais vu cela en Algérie et avec
des températures
inimaginables qui ont eu des
répercussions d'ailleurs sur les nappes
phréatiques de de l'eau donc
l'Algérie a mis en place des éléments
pour combattre à la fois les actes
criminels mais ça signifie pas il faut
comme la dit nos processeurs une
nouvelle culture et là moi je pense à
que ce soit pour l'Algérie ou d'autres
pays à l'implication de la société
civile à travers des associations moi
j'aime beaucoup les écrits de Jacques
Attali les futurs
activités de la nouvelle vie ce qu'ils
appellent et ça les industries d'avenir
et ça les Algériens sont sensibilisés à
ça depuis que la catastrophe qui a eu
lieu l'année passée à Tizi Ouzou où il y
a eu de nombreux morts je voudrais aller
un peu plus loin Hervé le truc est-ce
que vous pensez que 2 degrés de plus
c'est la catastrophe assurée est-ce
qu'on peut
mathématiquement arithmétiquement dire
qu'une élévation de degrés c'est
automatiquement le verre qui déborde
avec la catastrophe assurée
autrement dit s'il y avait pas eu de
degrés de plus est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas
connu
des phénomènes aussi intenses
je pense que la raison qu'on a déjà
montré enfin c'est effectivement face à
quelque chose qui est aujourd'hui engage
le futur je crois que c'est quelque
chose qui est mal compris cette idée on
n'est pas en train de
d'agir dans un cadre qui serait un cadre
un petit peu simple on a
on veut nettoyer un petit peu les choses
donc on passe un petit coup de chiffon
et ça marche non on engagé le futur sur
des périodes qui sont extrêmement
longues et ces périodes là on est
aujourd'hui en capacité de voir ce que
nous disent parce que on a on a un
retour en arrière ça fait déjà quelques
années qui nous montre effectivement que
le système climatique il est en train
d'évoluer que cette évolution est
irrémerciée est irréversible on le voit
dans les océans on le voit dans l'état
de domaine donc oui on est dans un dans
un domaine où on va être obligé de
regarder les choses avec beaucoup de
beaucoup de précisions les
des émissions de gaz effet de serre des
20 dernières années nous disent à Seb
fortement ce que vont être les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre les 20
prochaines années donc on est dans un
cadre qui évolue qu'on se fait pas
auquel on prête pas beaucoup d'attention
en fait on prépare énormément
d'attention à la planète parce qu'elle
est en fait pourtant c'est une planète
qui qui nous dit beaucoup de choses et
on doit je pense faire très attention à
cela parce que ça a été dit c'est ça
peut survenir dans différents endroits
et ces différents endroits seront jamais
tout à fait les mêmes mais ils nous
disent quand même
il y a un danger qui est un danger qu'on
est voir en fait de prendre en compte
dès maintenant je pense
je sais que notre conversation va
s'interrompre avec vous donc avant que
vous nous quittiez est-ce que vous
pouvez nous apporter deux ou trois
précisions est-ce que dans
l'accumulation
des phénomènes que ce soit les
catastrophes naturelles à la fois la
sécheresse et les inondations est-ce que
vous voyez des liens entre ces
catastrophes et est-ce que vous pensez
que ce que nous avons connu
cet été 2022 se reproduira en 2023 où
est-ce que c'était exceptionnel
non moi je pense que vraiment c'est
quelque chose qui était qui n'est pas
exceptionnel qui va se reproduire
effectivement dans le futur on voit les
immeubles un rythme qui est celui qu'on
a connu depuis maintenant beaucoup
d’années c'est-à-dire que quand on
regarde les chiffres simplement les
chiffres les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre n'ont pas cessé d'augmenter donc
on se confronte face à cela aujourd'hui
et je pense que c'est des choses qui
sont inévitables à ce stade inévitable
après il y aura un niveau de
dommage qui va dépendre de ce qu'on a de
ce que l'on va faire de ce que l'on va
mettre en jeu mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas en capacité
de d'empêcher ce qui est en train de se
passer et le lien entre sécheresse et
inondations vous le voyez ou pas
c'est-à-dire c'est un enchaînement
global où ce sont des phénomènes
indépendants les uns des autres
il y a avant tout un phénomène global
qui est celui des émissions de gaz effet
de serre et au-delà de cela on a toute
une série de choses qui sont
effectivement
lié les unes aux autres de manière un
peu complexe on peut pas prétendre qu'on
sait au détail près ce qui va se passer
mais en gros quand même on est face à un
système qui évolutif et qu'il est de
manière forte
en tout cas je vous remercie infiniment
d'avoir apporté le point de vue éclairé
du scientifique et qui va nous permettre
de poursuivre cette émission sur ces
points là brise la Londe un commentaire
il fait de plus en plus chaud parce
qu'il y a de plus en plus de gaz à effet
de serre pas simplement le gaz
carbonique le CO2 mais il y a un gaz qui
me fait très peur c'est le méthane parce
que il n'arrête pas de s'accumuler dans
l'atmosphère et on ne sait pas d'où
vient la totalité de se m'étonne donc
c'est très préoccupant alors qu'est-ce
qui se passe quand il fait plus chaud et
ben l'air plus l'air est chaud plus il
transporte de vapeur d'eau
donc il y a une évaporation qui est très
grande l'air prend cette cette masse de
vapeur d'eau et quand ça évapore ça
assèche donc c'est assez stress et puis
à un moment donné de cette vapeur d'eau
à un moment donné elle va tomber quelque
part et ce qui va tomber ça s'appelle
maintenant les rivières atmosphériques
c'est quasiment l'équivalent du
Mississippi à son embouchure et ça tombe
sur un endroit qui n'est pas du tout
préparé à ça et donc ça crée des
inondations alors d'un point de vue
politique quelle est la responsabilité
de l'État elle est pas négligeable qu'il
s'agisse du manque d'équipement de
moyens de surveillance de prévision des
risques on l'a vu on a eu besoin des
pompiers européens est-ce qu'il faudrait
refonder les politiques publiques en
fonction de l'impératif écologique
monsieur salmon effectivement on l'a vu
il y a du court terme il y a du long
terme et le moyen terme entre les deux
bien entendu le court terme c'est la
lutte contre l'incendie on le sait dans
les années à venir on aura de plus en
plus d'incendie et de plus en plus qu'on
appelle les mégafeux on voit aujourd'hui
que la France ne sait pas outiller pour
cela pas plus que l'Europe on est
vraiment en deçà de ce qu'il faudrait en
termes de lutte incendie on devait
commander de nouveau Canada enfin les
successeurs des Canadairs on l'a pas
fait donc on se repose un peu sur
l'Europe mais aujourd'hui il faut
vraiment que l'on prenne ce sujet là à
bras le corps parce que ces incendies
c'est 9 millions de 9 millions de tonnes
de CO2 qui sont partis en atmosphère
donc ça ne vient qu'à amplifier des
boucles de rétroaction qui font qu'on a
de plus en plus de particules par
millions on est passé à 420 particules
par millions on était qu'à 380 en 2006
et avant l'air industrielle on était à
280 vous voyez bien que c'est une courbe
exponentielle et donc il faut qu'on le
soit prêt à agir parce que on va voir
des nouveaux incendies demain il faut
également avoir une répartition
géographique plus plus harmonieuse parce
que il va falloir agir un peu partout
être prêt partout Fabienne Keller j'ai
vu que vous semblez pas complètement
d'accord sur l'insuffisance des je pense
que il faut être équipé préparer
entraîner à toutes les échelles à
l'échelle locale on a dit tout à l'heure
combien était important d'être vigilant
les propriétaires individuels voilà
nettoie les sous-bois autour de leur
maison pour éviter la la diffusion de
l'incendie au niveau local départemental
communal évidemment au niveau national
bien sûr il faut s'équiper puis au
niveau européen il y a cette force
européenne de sécurité civile qui a
toute sa pertinence un certain nombre
d'aéronef notamment de politique
publiques doivent être refondées à
partir de l'impératif écologique alors
là on est au regard des catastrophes qui
se sont uniquement réponse aux
catastrophes une fois qu'elles sont là
une fois que l'incendie est là comment
on peut la réserver pour éviter que ça
se transforme en une vraie catastrophe
par par la destruction d'un grand massif
l'année dernière cette force européenne
elle est intervenue en Grèce et je crois
bien en Algérie en soutient des moyens
nationaux de l'Algérie cette année ils
étaient très présents en dans les Landes
moi j'étais très touchée il se trouve
que j'ai circulé un moment donné j'ai
croisé des pompiers du Var qui
revenaient du Sud-Ouest on voit aussi la
coopération entre région parce que voilà
les pompiers du Sud-Est ont une grande
expérience mais ça c'est pour gérer la
catastrophe une fois qu'elle est là mais
il faut évidemment qu'on travaille sur
le moyen et surtout le long terme
notamment au niveau européen nous nous
fixons des objectifs pour émettre moins
de gaz à effet de serre parce qu'il y a
pas de doute le professeur l'a dit les
gaz à effet de serre et brise Lalonde
aussi ça génère en fait du dérèglement
climatique c'est beaucoup de
réchauffement mais aussi des phénomènes
de pluie plus violent de moussons
volontaire mais qui n'a pas un seul
niveau de pertinence qui est
complémentaire et chacun sera conforté
dans son action dans son investissement
parce que les autres au niveau de
responsabilité il contribueront la COP
21 a permis de faire poser un certain
nombre de marqueurs il faut que d'autres
coques y contribuent au niveau
planétaire au niveau européen au niveau
de l'Amérique du Nord il faut qu'il y
ait une volonté au niveau national etc
je crois qu'il faut ça sert à rien de se
renvoyer la responsabilité on a besoin
de tous les acteurs et notamment d'une
participation et d'une explication à la
population parce que tout ça si ça
suppose un certain nombre de contraintes
ça ne peut être acceptable que si chacun
porte cette cet objectif et le
comprendre Daniel allemand juste une
petite remarque effectivement on a
peut-être eu dans notre malheur un peu
de chance cette année c'est-à-dire qu'on
a eu des feux dans le Sud-Ouest et on a
rien eu dans le sud-est mais il faut
s'attendre dans les années à venir qu'on
puisse avoir des foyers dans différents
endroits de France mais aussi d'Europe
donc c'est pour ça qu'il va falloir
augmenter forcément les moyens il faut
qu'on soit prêt à lutter sur plusieurs
fronts et là on n'est pas à la hauteur
il va falloir vraiment investir
[Musique]
revenons aux catastrophes naturelles
elles ont toujours existé comme le
réchauffement climatique mais il y a une
accélération des phénomènes tout n'est
pas prévisible comme on vient de le dire
et les marges d'imprévus existent mais
ce qu'il y a pas un fossé entre les
objectifs affichés la réalité parce que
autrement dit le climat n'est-il pas
devenu aujourd'hui incontrôlable Brice
Lalonde il a toujours été incontournable
le climat simplement maintenant l'homme
est en train de le modifier sans que
l'on sache exactement ce qu'il va
devenir ce climat on le voit devenir de
plus en plus inhospitalier de plus en
plus brutale donc ça on ne sait donc en
effet il va falloir changer les
politiques parce qu'on sait très bien
quelle est l'origine de ce réchauffement
on sait très bien que ce sont des
combustibles fossiles comme on dit on
brûle du pétrole en boule du charbon au
bout du gaz naturel à chaque fois qu'on
brûle ses combustible on envoie dans
l'air un manteau de CO2 qui piéger la
chaleur réfléchi par la terre et
réchauffer l'atmosphère donc on sait
très bien donc il faut le faire
maintenant et on ne le fait pas et il
faut sans doute changer la politique de
l'eau parce qu'il y a pas de neige et
donc ça veut dire quoi pas de neige ça
veut dire qu'il va pleuvoir beaucoup
plus en hiver et pas du tout en été et
donc il va falloir garder cette eau il
va la recycler donc toute la politique
de l'eau est à revoir surtout qu'on en
aura besoin pour lutter contre les
incendies etc donc oui en effet il faut
revoir complètement les politiques de
rapport à la nature comment est-ce qu'on
gère les ressources comment est-ce qu'on
va chercher notre énergie et comment va
l'utiliser ça s'appelle
l'électrification c'est plus ou moins en
cours dans les pays développés plus ou
moins en cours simplement c'est lent
c'est trop lent en revanche dans les
pays en développement eux ils veulent se
développer à juste titre on ne comprend
comment on va les aider donc nous
manquons de solidarité planétaire et
nous manquons donne des tas qui est la
vision alors l'Algérie qui est un pays
producteur d'hydrocarbures qu'est-ce que
fait l'Algérie en matière de politique
du climat bon moi je voudrais d'abord je
viens de recevoir un rapport de l'ONU
qui est alarmant qui est alarmant disons
que on est passé de 1
degrés Celsius on tend vers 1,5 et si
rien n'est fait pour la planète en 2100
c'est 4,4 c'est ça veut dire c'est
presque la destruction de la l'humanité
et le rapport de l'OCDE dit que si on ne
fait rien il va avoir une décroissance
de 6% du PIB mondial en 2050 et de 13%
en 2100 c'est à dire que le coût de
cette décroissance par rapport aux
investissements qu'il faudrait opérer
ces disproportionné donc il faut revoir
totalement notre modèle de consommation
énergétique au niveau mondial et là ça
pose un problème tout le problème de la
transition énergétique
de l'Algérie l'alternant le climat pour
l'Algérie
elle a
d'abord adhéré au cop21 allô Hua elle
vient de déposer sous l'égide du
président de la République un plan
national du climat qu'elle a déposé à
l'Organisation de l'Unité Africaine
disons qu'il faut que ça soit coordonné
pour toute la condition de de l'Afrique
et c'est à engagé à réduire de 7% ces
émissions de terre avec une projection
de 20% horizon 2030 il y a tout un plan
effectivement
pour effectivement aller vers les
énergies renouvelables il y a eu la
Premier ministre française qui était en
Algérie madame borne il y a eu des
accords sur la transition énergétique
mais c'est surtout les contrats qu'on
vient de signer avec la commissaire
européenne à l'énergie qui s'est engagée
du fait que à faire de telle sorte que
l'Algérie que ces énergies de
renouvelables en consommation intérieure
soit de 50%, et à peu près 10 000 si on
arrive à faire des contrats avec
l'Europe 10 000 mégawatts heure
exportations sur l'Europe à travers des
interconnexions mais uniquement le gaz
mais uniquement
un plan actuel en Algérie pour se passer
dans 10 ans dans 20 ans dans 30 ans des
hydrocarbures dans 50 ans pour aller
vers des énergies propres est-ce qu'il y
a un plan social plan il y a un
investissement qui est prévu
horizon 2022 2030 2035 de 60 à 70
milliards de dollars oui mais d'accord
mais pour faire quoi pour aller vers les
énergies renouvelables c'est les
investissements dans cet agriculaire le
solaire le voltaïque et le thermique
parce qu'il faut bien qu'on se mette
dans la tête que le pour la consommation
intérieure et le thermique à travers des
interconnexions vers l'Europe même
l'Europe pour ne pas trop dépendre du
gaz russe vous avez intérêt aller vers
une transition énergétique accélérée bon
alors justement Fabienne Keller
qu'est-ce que l'Europe attend de pays
comme l'Algérie qui sont producteurs
d'hydrocarbures et qui sont qui ont une
position forte au niveau de l'Afrique
alors c'est un partenaire donc on
respecte d'abord ses choix propres mais
bien sûr les échanges en matière de
technologie
notamment sur les énergies renouvelables
les technologies de concentration de
chaleur sont très intéressants parce que
voilà vous évidemment plus plus de
soleil
mais plus largement cette transition
énergétique elle doit être construite à
l'échelle de chaque espace géographique
l'Europe a construit sa stratégie pour
être neutre en carbone en 2050
qui est assez fondamental dans les
relations avec les pays du Maghreb les
pays africains à cause de cette fameuse
double peine vous savez qu'ils sont
beaucoup plus touchés par les
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
vous évoquez des températures qui nous
donnent qui nous font extrêmement peur
50 degrés nous devons prendre en compte
le fait qu'ils sont les premières
victimes de notre
de notre réchauffement climatique
collectif mais donc quand même les pays
occidentaux sont largement à l'origine
Daniel salmon est-ce que vous pensez que
cette politique
contre le réchauffement climatique elle
est transfrontière et elle doit être
globale puisque le climat lui
n'obéit pas des frontières notamment
dans son réchauffement bien entendu la
problématique et les planétaire nous
sommes tous que de petits terriens
inféodés à notre planète et il faut agir
effectivement
partout et nous avons nous occidentaux
impassifs ça fait deux siècles que nous
extrayons du fossile donc effectivement
nous devons aider à la transition
écologique tous les pays qui eux
subissent les conséquences sans avoir
produit beaucoup de gaz à effet de serre
donc il faut y aller j'y étais
dernièrement au Népal en tant que
président du groupe d'amitié France
Népal le Népal au pied de l'Himalaya un
potentiel d'hydroélectricité fantastique
50 gigawatts peut-être 100 GW il faut
absolument que nous ayons un partenariat
tout en respectant bien entendu leur
volonté mais ils attendent un
partenariat pour que nos compétences
nous françaises qui sont quand même
importantes dans le domaine des barrages
nous puissions avec eux travailler sur
une électrification de leur pays il faut
absolument qu'il passe
de pratiquement peu de consommation
fossiles à plus du tout de consommation
fossiles le pas vers l'électricité doit
être très rapide donc on se doit on se
doit d'avoir des partenariats et de les
aider mais j'ai parlé du Népal mais
c'est partout dans le monde où je pense
que on a une exigence à deux voir
d'investir très rapidement et d'aider
tous ces pays est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il faut mettre un bémol à ça on
regarde la guerre en Ukraine des risques
de panne d'énergie
regardez l'Allemagne en revient à ces
centrales à charbon elle a même elle
maintient même de réacteurs nucléaires
la France est moins dépendante du
charbon mais néanmoins
on a un besoin un petit peu est-ce que
là dessus vous comprenez que il y a des
urgences aussi
il y a des urgences ça c'est très clair
on paye aujourd'hui cash des années
d'innaction des décennies d'innactions
ça c'est très clair il y a deux mots qui
avaient disparu du vocabulaire sauf un
peu chez les écologistes c'était la
planification et la sobriété et je me
réjouis de les voir repris aujourd'hui
il y a encore quelques mois le président
de la République nous traitait d'amish
dès qu'on parlait de ce briété et bien
allons-y sur la sobriété c'est quand
même essentiel d'aller sur une sobriété
forte mais une sobriété partagée il n'y
aura pas de sobriété si on ne lutte pas
contre les inégalités on parlait des
responsabilités en préalable tout à
l'heure les responsabilités elles ne
sont pas identiques entre tous les
habitants de la planète quand il y a un
vote échelle de responsabilité par
rapport aux catastrophes les États les
individus les entreprises il faut bien
tout cela est très systémique il y a
beaucoup de victimes mais il y a des
victimes consentantes également comme
disait Coluche il suffirait que les
citoyens ne l'achètent pas pour que ça
ne se vende pas donc on peut pas accuser
les entreprises non plus de tous les
mots puisque l'acheteur le client il est
là donc c'est au client aussi de de
travailler sur sa consommation sur son
mode de vie mais les entreprises ont
quand même une grosse responsabilité
parce que aujourd'hui on a quand même un
formatage à la consommation vous savez
les budgets faramineux qui sont alloués
pour la publicité il faut d'abord jouer
sur cette publicité pour qu'on arrête de
faire du citoyen un simple consommateur
donc c'est la base il faut vraiment
réinterroger nos modes de consommation
sinon on n'ira pas bien loin alors je
voudrais je sais vous avez été ministre
l'environnement mais vous avez été
également
ambassadeur pour le climat et c'est à
cette fonction internationale
du fait de cette casquette si vous me
permettez ça que je voudrais vous poser
une question des catastrophes naturelles
impactent l'ensemble de la planète et
provoque migration de masse des
modifications famine cet aspect
conflictuel provoquer directement par
les entraves écologiques
ne sont pas pris en compte comme une
priorité stratégique par les
institutions internationales
est-ce qu'il faut pas faire autre chose
est-ce qu'il y a pas un Conseil de
sécurité sur l'environnement à créer
est-ce qu'il y a pas est-ce qu'il faut
pas
attendre la prochaine catastrophe pour
envisager une régulation internationale
alors d'abord
ce serait bien que l'on arrête le
conflit actuel parce que ce conflit est
certainement
contradictoire avec la lutte contre le
changement climatique puisque parler du
conflit de la guerre en Ukraine
déclenchée par la Russie et nous sommes
nous sommes entourés de bout de feu des
deux côtés qui veulent aller jusqu'au
bout je ne sais pas ce que c'est que le
bout mais ce que je sais c'est qu'il
faudrait mieux arrêter et il voudrait
mieux trouver un système qui nous
permette d'engager des pourparlers et de
revenir ensuite à la lutte principale on
a vu qu'il a lutte contre le changement
climatique parce qu'autrement on y
arrivera pas et c'était évident qu'il
faut qu'il y ait une coopération
internationale et que si tout le monde
s'engueule on y arrivera évidemment pas
et donc qu'est-ce qui va se passer nous
avons une réunion à Charmed cher bientôt
qui est la COP numéro 27 vous rendez
compte déjà la 27
ce qui est très clair c'est que les pays
développés les pays riches ils peuvent
réduire leurs émissions c'est leur job
réduire les émissions inventer les
techniques de demain c'est leur job et
aider les autres les autres leur grand
problème les pays en voie de
développement leur grand problème c'est
l'adaptation eux ils sont condamnés à
s'adapter comment fait-on pour s'adapter
comment fait-on pour s'adapter aux
grandes chaleurs en Inde comment fait-on
pour s'adapter à des moussons déréglées
il faut les aider à s'adapter donc on a
cette espèce de partage mondiale des
tâches urgentes en ce moment bon faisons
ça et nous en France qu'est-ce que nous
devons faire réduire la demande
d'hydrocarbure on va pas demander à
l'Algérie d'arrêter de d'exporter on va
dire on en a plus besoin donc on va
progressivement réduire la demande c'est
ça notre job si on réduit les demandes
on réduit l'offre aussi donc parfait
mais c'est d'abord par la demande qu'on
va réussir on va pas dire arrêter de
robinet c'est à nous d'arrêter de
consommer c'est prendre l'exemple des
voitures on a fait des zones à faible
émission dans les dans les villes mais
les zones a fait 1800 dans les villes
elles empêchent les gens des voitures
diesel d'entrée donc cette attentatoire
aux libertés
ça veut dire quoi ça ça veut dire que la
priorité des priorités c'est
l'électrification des véhicules dans le
monde rural français parce que le monde
rural français qu'on oublie généralement
il est condamné à avoir des voitures
donc aidons le à passer aux voitures
électriques il y a un certain nombre de
priorités qui à mon avis sont mal
établies donc essayons de rétablir les
bonnes priorités et d'avancer et ce
qu'il faut des régulations
internationales est-ce qu'il vaudrait
mieux y en avoir il y en a pas pourquoi
parce que le système des Nations Unies
n'est pas capable d'imposer quoi que ce
soit c'est un système volontaire donc ce
qu'il faudrait déjà à mon avis ce qu'il
faudrait créer c'est une espèce de
fondation qui vérifie que les
engagements politiques soient suivis des
faits
il y a tellement d'engagements
politiques magnifiques on va tout
réduire en 30 ans ça va être formidable
et c'est pas suivi des faits il faut il
faut maintenant que la parole politique
soit respectée respectable d'abord et
donc vérifier que à chaque fois les
engagements soient réellement suivis
appliqués c'est le cas en Europe va bien
de Keller il y a cette volonté politique
oui le conseil comme le Parlement
européen dès l'installation 2019 on fixé
des objectifs très clairs 2030 baisse de
55% des émissions 2050 neutralité
carbone c'est extrêmement ambitieux
alors maintenant il faut les remplir je
rappelle que la COP a prévu des
instruments d'évaluation la question
c'est de les mettre en oeuvre et de
partager les réalisations dans chaque
État membre en termes de conversion
industrielle de mode de modalité de
transport en terme de d'objectif bien
sûr il faut accompagner cela par des
financements adéquats la sobriété à
toute sa place gardez l'essentiel de
notre bien vivre mais en isolant mieux
nos bâtiments en utilisant plus souvent
des transports moins émetteurs chaque
fois que c'est possible on favorisant
l'électrification des transports même en
milieu rural alors on attend la mise en
oeuvre mais je rappelle que le président
Macron s'est engagé et moi-même je m'y
suis engagée à ce qui est accès à des
véhicules électriques pour des personnes
modestes ayant obligation de s'en servir
notamment par exemple les personnes qui
vont d'une personne âgée à l'autre en
milieu rurale ou qui assure la
logistique donc il faut la impulser des
politiques nouvelles moi je suis très
touchée par le vélo électrique qui
apparaît y compris en milieu rural de
manière beaucoup plus présente des
solutions pragmatiques qui permettent à
chacun de contribuer mais aussi un appui
au niveau national et au niveau européen
je dois dire que l'Europe est très
déterminée sur ces sujets consciente de
sa responsabilité sur le moyen et long
terme
est-ce que l'Union africaine a la même
volonté politique que l'Union européenne
d'avoir une politique orientée j'allais
dire contre le réchauffement climatique
et est-ce que l'Algérie en particulier
prend conscience de cette chose là en
développant l'électro mobilité par
exemple les véhicules électriques les
bicyclettes électriques pour le cas de
l'Algérie vient de présenter un rapport
il y a une semaine à l'Organisation de
l'Unité Africaine un rapport de la
présidence de la République disons qu'il
faut
lors de la réunion du Caire que
l'Afrique du Caire se rappelle que c'est
la cop27 voilà que l'Afrique parle du
même voie et le rapport qu'a présenté
l'Algérie a été adopté à 90% de voix par
tous les membres de
qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans ce rapport
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de concret
dans ce domaine du réchauffement
climatique bon il y a un problème de
développer effectivement les énergies
renouvelables bon on a d'abord
l'efficacité énergétique et la sobriété
on ne peut plus construire les 2
millions les dizaines de millions de
sur les mêmes méthodes sinon il faut un
climatiseur par Pierre il y a un élément
très important moi j'ai une équipe sous
ma direction à Sonatrach a beaucoup
travaillé là-dessus attention le gaz est
moins nocif que le pétrole ou le charbon
on pourrait combiner
à la fois le gaz et le solaire bon
l'Algérie c'est 3000 heures de soleil
par an c'est c'est ce que vient de dire
la commissaire européenne à l'énergie
disons que
l'Europe ils ont inventorial certains
nombre de projets concrets pas
uniquement de la parole qui vont être
mis en place dans les deux trois mois
entre la commission europ et l'Algérie
vient l'Afrique bien l'Afrique donc le
grand problème la sobriété énergétique
les énergies
renouvelables bon l'hydroélectricité
comme le monsieur vient de le dire
encore que ça concerne que quelques pays
d'Afrique et à tout un problème du entre
l'Égypte et l'Éthiopie pour le fameux
barrage on va en parler il faut trouver
la solution de provoquer des guerres
donc il y a des solutions mais comme l'a
dit Madame la responsabilité des effets
de serre
avant tout des pays développés donc
maintenant comment concilier un peu
comme a dit bon les pays développés dont
la Chine faut pas oublier la Chine
donc c'est la Chine grandement
responsable aussi des effets de serre
donc c'est des pays qui aspirent au
développement donc maintenant comment
concilier les deux c'est un véritable
problème
pour les gouvernements en Afrique bref
le climat est un problème sans
frontières et qui concerne l'ensemble de
la planète
[Musique]
on va passer maintenant à une question
qui concerne spécialement l'eau la
question de l'eau et centrale tant au
niveau des sécheresses parce que pour
les combattre il fallait de l'eau
qu'avec les inondations et tous les
dégâts
occasionnés est-ce qu'il faut à ce
niveau des réglementations qui soient
plus efficace et plus rigoureuse
Fabienne Keller certainement mais adapté
pour chaque territoire il y a des
territoires qui ont une eau abondante
des nappes phréatiques assez solide
enfin robuste sur plusieurs décennies il
y a d'autres territoires qui sont très
directement touchés par le la sécheresse
en l'an vu cet été avec le Sud-Ouest le
sud-est extrêmement fragilisé donc un
monde agricole qui avait l'habitude de
d'irriguer qui ne peut plus parce qu'on
est obligé pour protéger la consommation
humaine de réduire les arrosages
agricoles
90% de l'usage de l'eau en été
l'agriculture donc on a des modèles qui
sont assez dispendieux
quelle eau on utilise est-ce qu'on pompe
directement est-ce que ça peut être des
eaux de stockage soit individuels soit
plus collectif et puis il faut avoir
conscience qu'on est une région dans le
monde enfin s'agissant de l'Europe qui
est plutôt bien doté en nous il y a
d'autres endroits en Afrique dans
dans l'Asie centrale ou les les
ressources en eau sont d'ores et déjà
plus fragiles et générant des
compétitions on peut rappeler que l'eau
historiquement est souvent été à
l'origine de guerre le long des fleuves
parce que ce qui est prélevé
donc oui il faut trouver des règles mais
là aussi prenant en compte l'ensemble du
cycle de l'eau avec différents acteurs
qui utilisent la ressource et puis
peut-être se préparer aux mesures qui
ont été prises en grande urgence cet été
mais qui risque d'être plus
régulièrement
de manière à préserver la ressource oui
Daniel salmon sur cette régulation il
faut il faut avoir aller plus loin et
être plus ambitieux aujourd'hui
clairement il faut regarder où sont les
consommations vous l'avez dit mais sur
l'année l'agriculture effectivement
c'est que pratiquement 50% à 50 % de la
consommation d'eau aujourd'hui on le
sait il va falloir s'adapter parce que
le réchauffement il est en cours et on
va pas pouvoir l'arrêter comme ça d'un
claquement de doigts donc il va falloir
que l'agriculture s'adapte qu'on aille
vers une agriculture beaucoup plus
résiliente beaucoup moins consommatrice
d'eau effectivement l'irrigation ne va
pas être possible partout et donc il y a
certaines types de culture très
gourmands en eau qu'il va falloir
changer très clairement et puis après on
peut regarder les autres consommations
d'eau on sait aujourd'hui par exemple
que les notre rentres réacteurs
nucléaire consomme 20% de l'eau 20% 70%
d'électricité
si on regarde le brut c'est
effectivement il 98% de l'eau qui est
remise dans le panneau mais ce que je
vous dis les 20% ça correspond aux 2 %
qui sont partis dans l'atmosphère vous
regarder les chiffres et donc
aujourd'hui effectivement il va falloir
voir où sont les consommations pour
pouvoir les réduire au maximum alors
bien sûr il y a les petits gestes du
particulier tout le monde a sa part à
faire mais il y a des petits gestes et
puis il y a des grands gestes donc il va
falloir regarder ça de très près donc
l'agriculture est en pointe pour
s'adapter et il va falloir aussi voir
les stockages et le meilleur stockage
c'est dans les nappes phréatiques donc
il faut adapter quand je veux parler de
l'agriculture il faut adapter
l'agriculture pour essayer de faire en
sorte que les épisodes plus vieux qu'on
va voir qui vont être de plus en plus
intenses mais de plus en plus court ce
qui va arriver là il faut arriver à le
faire pénétrer dans le sol et qu'il
n'aille pas directement dans les cours
d'eau et ensuite à la mer donc il faut
vraiment s'engager sur ce sur ce
stockage mais le meilleur stockage c'est
dans les nappes phréatiques bon alors on
a parlé des guerres de l'eau et je pense
que on va
ponctuer cette émission avec ce sujet
alors ces guerres de l'eau c'est les
tensions entre les pays qui ont un
fleuve en partage mais pas que alors il
y a tous les problèmes entre l'Egypte et
l'Éthiopie à propos du Nil l'Ukraine la
Russie l'impact
etc ce problème ce stress hydrique à
l'échelle de la planète
finalement l'agenda international
l'ignore pourquoi et pourtant
ça risque de provoquer des des dégâts
considérables
alors
je crois que vous vous trompez
l'UNESCO et d'autres travaillent
beaucoup à ce qu'on appelle
l'hydrodiplomatie et il y a eu beaucoup
de contacts beaucoup de réunions et si
vous prenez les fleuves du Moyen-Orient
la plupart des fleuves du Moyen-Orient
ont des accords de partage de l'eau mais
de l'eau de surface et le grand problème
c'est plutôt le souterraine parce que là
pour le coup c'est le premier service
qui se qui se sert et là il y a pas
d'accord donc le grand problème là vous
avez raison c'est sur les eaux
souterraines les nappes phréatiques et
certaines en Afrique ça sèche parce
qu'elles sont fossiles et donc elles ne
se renouvelle pas aussi vite qu'elles
sont pompées donc là il y a une vraie
difficulté mais pour le reste non il y a
coopération il y a jamais eu de guerre
réellement à sauf dans l'Antiquité alors
mais pas vraiment il y a eu des des
attaques si je puis dire notamment
un Bagdad ou autre enfin à Mossoul sur
les présidents là elles ont été ciblées
par les guerriers quoi en quelque sorte
par les djihadistes et autres mais sinon
non jusqu'à présent heureusement
l'humanité a été assez sage pour
partager l'eau mais les difficultés sont
devant nous on va dessaler le
dessalement qu'on le veuille ou non est
devenu une industrie mondiale partout en
des salles la Méditerranée en première
même l'Espagne des salles et donc on y
échappera pas on va dessaler on va
partager
la seule chose si vous voulez c'est
qu'il faut changer la politique de l'eau
au sens où on ne rejette plus l'eau il
faut il faut recycler l'eau une fois que
l'eau est passée chez vous et qu'elle
est à la station d'épuration on a pas du
tout il faut la garder la récupérer la
recycler stocker etc donc on est à
l'aube d'une révolution de la police de
l'eau qui est le recyclage on va s'en
resservir on va se servir de l'eau de
pluie pour aller pour les toilettes et
cetera on en fait de plus en plus
intelligent avec l'eau parce que vous
savez personne ne le sait mais c'est
l'eau le principal gaz à effet de serre
c'est la vapeur d'eau et puis il fait
chaud plus il y a de vapeur d'eau dans
l'atmosphère plus ça augmente l'effet de
serre donc si vous voulez c'est pas
c'est pas la vapeur d'eau qui est
responsable du changement climatique
mais c'est la vapeur d'eau qui
l'accentue tout simplement parce qu'il y
a de plus en plus nous dans l'atmosphère
je crois monsieur webto vous avez
quelque chose à dire sur ces fameuses
guerres de l'eau non moi d'abord je
voudrais souligner d'abord que au désert
il y a à peu près 15000 ans vous savez
que c'était
la prospérité c'était des arbres etc bon
le désert celle le plus grand
océan du monde
60000 milliards de mètres cubes d'eau 60
000 dans 70% en Afrique en Afrique 60 et
non renouvelable
70% pour l'Algérie 20% pour la Libye
rendez-vous le fameux barrage de Kadhafi
d'ailleurs où il a fait une catastrophe
c'est des affaissements lorsque vous
allez boire et 10% en Tunisie ça c'est
un élément très très important mais il
faut faire très très attention nous on a
fait une canalisation
pour approvisionner effectivement mais
il faut faire d'après les écologistes
attention de ne pas briser l'écosystème
l'Algérie a opté pour les unités de
dessalement elle a opté ce elle va
investir massivement sur une vingtaine
trentaine d'unités de dessalement
horizon 2030 bon c'est parce que l'eau
n'a pas de prix ça coûte très très cher
et donc
l'autre élément c'est que il y a des
déperditions en Algérie la dépétition
parce que c'est des anciens tuyaux c'est
à peu près 32%. là il faut voir aussi
les de revoir toutes les canalisations
les déperditions et tout l'eau c'est à
dire les puits torrentielles qui sont
déversé sur la mer il faut des retenues
et l'autre élément pour l'agriculture il
faut d'autres méthodes comme le
goutte-à-goutte le goutte-à-goutte ou
des méthodes qui font des économies
d'eau très bien donc vous l'Algérie a
une politique très rationnelle
parce que on a pris conscience que le
combien de le dire monsieur le ministre
l'eau ou madame il faut préserver hier
ça va être la guerre alors écoutez le
temps est parti est terminé si je puis
dire en deux mots je voudrais vous dire
au moins une note optimiste parce que
c'est quand même ce problème du climat
inquiète beaucoup de gens à juste titre
s'inquiète du réchauffement climatique
c'est parmi les jeunes générations qu'on
trouve l'engagement écologique le plus
sincère qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
Fabienne Keller les jeunes nous obligent
par cette l'utilisation tout à fait
impressionnante moi je vais au contact
là des manifestations du vendredi
après-midi je le retrouve une belle
énergie l'enjeu c'est peut-être de leur
proposer des modes d'action qui
permettent de participer à la limitation
de ce réchauffement ou l'atténuation de
ces cons de ses conséquences mais qu'on
passe dans dans l'action concrète et la
contribution à un meilleur vivre
ensemble plus respectueux de
l'environnement c'est pour votre avis
Daniel salmon l'espoir vient de la
genèse de ce côté-là
engage l'espoir vient toujours de la
jeunesse parce que nous on est amené à
disparaître un jour ou l'autre donc
effectivement mais la jeunesse n'est pas
monolithique il y a des gens beaucoup de
jeunes qui sont conscients complètement
d'autres qui sont conscients mais sans
le transformer dans leur vie de tous les
jours et qui reste encore des
consommateurs donc c'est cela qui va
falloir changer je rebondis simplement
sur sur l'eau beaucoup d'eau est
consommé pour des cultures d'exportation
on le sait aujourd'hui quand on change
de jeans très régulièrement on consomme
énormément d'eau donc la jeunesse il
faut qu'elle se mette dans ce
développement durable et il faut qu'on
l'incite et c'est une question de
connaissances et de pédagogie en
croissance ou des croissances pour
terminer je veux pas polémiquer mais
écoutez quand on parle de sobriété ça
veut dire que dans certains domaines on
fait de la décroissance mais quand on
dit sobriété ça veut dire que quand on
fait plein d'isolation des maisons on va
faire de la croissance donc voilà je
vais pas rentrer dans le débats Lalande
croissance des croissances là-dessus ça
je suis d'accord avec vous alors vous
êtes voilà un accord qui se conclut au
cours de cette émission je vous
présenter une bibliographie tout
comprendre ou presque sur le climat
c'est un manuel collectif publié au CNRS
édition les auteurs sont
bons potes Anne breize Claire Marc il y
a une préface de Valérie Masson Delmotte
Fabienne Keller vous avez publié nouveau
horizons pour Strasbourg je sais que
vous êtes maintenant un peu loin mais
toujours près du près de oui et
Strasbourg très européenne j'offre au
Parlement européen qui a son siège à
Strasbourg
le Parlement européen à Strasbourg je
crois que la démocratie européenne est
bien Strasbourg quand le Parlement
s'exprime il est loin des lobbies
Bruxelles Waha et puis c'est aussi cette
Europe décentralisée l'Europe elle est
forte de sa diversité sa multiplicité de
centre de capital on parlait de Budapest
tout à l'heure le capital qui ont leur
histoire et leur rayonnement leur
sensibiliser à l'environnement aussi
beaucoup d'idées à trouver dans les dans
les réalisations des autres pays
européens climat parlons vrai alors un
ouvrage de jean-jouzel et Baptiste Denis
effectivement c'est un ouvrage classique
et qui apporte beaucoup de choses sur la
question du climat je voudrais également
signaler l'ouvrage de Brice Lalonde
excusez-moi de vous déranger
pourquoi vous vous excusez Brice Lalonde
vous êtes devenus vous êtes consensuel
aujourd'hui
parce que nous savons ce qu'il faut
faire maintenant et donc contre toutes
les
comment dire je les slogans les erreurs
je viens dire pardon on sait ce qu'il
faut faire on sait ce qu'il faut faire
il faut mettre des pompes à chaleur dans
les maisons il faut électrifier les
transports il faut mettre de l'hydrogène
dans l'industrie et allez on y va quoi
voilà allons-y comme de allons-y comme
dit Brice allande merci Madame merci
messieurs d'avoir participé coanimer
cette émission je voudrais remercier
l'équipe de LCP et avant de nous quitter
je voudrais vous soumettre cette pensée
on va voir si vous devinez de qui elle
est résoudre la crise climatique et le
défi le plus important et le plus
ambitieux que l'Homo sapiens s'est eu à
affronter la solution est pourtant si
simple que même un enfant pourrait la
comprendre la vérité par qui
alors j'aurais pu dire ça beaucoup de
gens bah c'est Greta Thunberg voilà
[Musique]